liam opened a savings account and put
six thousand two hundred fifty dollars
in it each year the account increases by
twenty percent
how many years will it take the account
to reach twelve thousand nine hundred
and sixty dollars write an equation that
models the situation use t to represent
the number of years since liam opened
the account
so i encourage you to pause this video
and actually try to do it on your own
first try to write this equation that
models the situation using the t
variable t and the way they described
and then actually answer the question
how many years will it take for the
account to reach 12 960.
well let's just think about it so t is
to represent the number of years since
liam opened the account so let's just
say it's been
zero years since liam opened the account
how much is he going to have well he's
just going to have 6250 in it we've
already that's how much he starts with
now let's say it's been one year
one year since he opened the account how
much will he have
well he's going to have 6250
times
or let's write it this way plus
plus 20
of
6250. it grows 20 every year
so this is how much he started the year
with and then he gets another twenty
percent of that six thousand two hundred
fifty if we factor out at six thousand
two hundred and fifty this is equal to
six thousand two hundred fifty
times
one plus 20 or we could write that as
0.2
which is equal to
which is equal to 6250
times 1.2
now how much is he going to have at the
end of two years
well he's going to have the same amount
that he had at the end of one year
times 1.2 because it grew by 20 percent
again
so he's going to have the amount that he
had at the end of one here times 1.2
times 1.2 which is equal to 6250
times 1.2
times 1.2 times 1.2
times
1.2 which is equal to
is equal to
6250 times 1.2 squared
1.2 squared i think you
might see where this is going i could
even write it like this order of
operations you do the exponent first so
what about after three years
so after three years well we're just
going to compound we're gonna multiply
by 1.2 once again so then he's going to
have
6250 times 1.2
to the third power and so after t years
we're going to multiply by 1.2 that many
times
so after t years in his account in his
account he's going to have
6250 times 1.2
1.2 to the teeth power
1.2
to the t power or to the t power i don't
want to get confused with a part of your
or i guess the thing that you used to
take bites with anyway
so they say write an equation that
models the situation so we want to
figure out how many years will it take
the account to reach 12
960. so we essentially want to say when
is
the account going to be 12 960 or we
could write 12 960
when is that going to be equal to
times
1.2
1.2 to the t power so that's the
equation right over there that models
the situation and then we need to think
about
then we need to think about how we can
actually go about solving this thing
well a natural thing is to isolate the t
variable let's divide both sides by 6
250 so we could get and if we flip the
two sides we could get 1.2 to the t
power
is equal to
1200 or let me write this 12
960 divided by 6250
six thousand two hundred and fifty and
since they're both divisible by ten why
don't we
why don't we divide them both by ten so
it's one thousand two hundred and
ninety-six divided by six hundred and
twenty-five and there's several ways
that you could solve this problem at
this point
one way if you feel confident that this
is going to have an integer answer right
over here you could literally just try
to use your calculator and multiply 1.2
enough times to get whatever number this
is and so we could do it that way and as
we'll see there's a more systematic way
of doing it once you learn about
logarithms and i'll do that at the end
but i'll do that last just in case you
haven't been exposed to logarithms yet
so you could literally say
so let me just let me just
exit out of everything
so you could literally say okay let's
see 12
96 divided by 625
is this value so let's see how many
times we have to multiply by 1.2 1.2
times 1.2
gets us well that doesn't get us close
enough so let's try it three times so
let's take that same number
let's take
let's just take
1.2
let's raise it let's raise 1.2
let's just do it three times times 1.2
times
1.2
that still doesn't get us there what if
we were to multiply by 1.2 one more time
well that actually gets us there so you
see if you want and we just did this by
brute force we mult 1.2 to the fourth
power will give us this value so that's
one way kind of a brute force way
of figuring out that t is equal to four
another way this might be a little bit
less intuitive it might jump out of it
this looks like some type of a power
five we know that five well five to the
first is five five squared is
twenty-five five to the third is 125.
five to the fourth is 625
and so you might recognize this right
over here is five to the fourth
and it's actually a little bit harder to
recognize that this right over here is
six to the fourth power and this right
over here is six-fifths so we could
rewrite this as
six over five to the t
is equal to
six to the fourth
over five to the fourth
over five to the fourth which is the
same thing
as six over five
six over five to the fourth power
so here you say well six over five to
the t
needs to be equal to six over five to
the fourth power t must be equal to 4.
now this is nice when you can recognize
that this is a this is a something
raised to the fourth power which isn't
easy to do or if you could just if you
know this is an integer you can just
keep multiplying 1.2 if you know it's a
low integer but the systematic way of
doing it is to actually use logarithms
and there's many videos on khan academy
about how to use logarithms but if
you're more concerned with well gee if i
if i just want to figure out 1.2 to what
power is equal to this thing what you do
and we explain we prove this in other
videos
is if you say look let's take the thing
that we want 1.2
to some power to be
let's take the logarithm of that and
actually you could take a logarithm any
base your calculator tends to have a
natural log which is base e and a log
base 10. we could just take log base 10.
so let's do that so we'll take the
logarithm of what we want to get to
2.0736
and divide that by the thing that we're
trying to take the power of to get to
this number so divided by the logarithm
of 1.2 and once again we prove this
actually i wanted to divide
so let me
let me insert a division symbol
so once again it might look like a
little voodoo right here we prove it in
other videos but if you wanted to use
the calculator to calculate things like
this because sometimes it won't be a
nice integer number of years it might be
three and a half years or it might be uh
seven point one two three four years
whatever it might be this will give you
a more precise answer so what what do
you want to get to you want to get to
2.0736 what are you raising to some
power 1.2 divide the log of the thing
you're trying to get to divided by the
log of what you're what you're taking
what the base that you're trying to
raise to a power and you click enter and
then you get so this is literally
another way of saying that 1.2 to the
fourth power
is going to be
2.0736 so once again if this looks like
voodoo you don't know what logarithms
are we have videos on khan academy on
that but there's multiple ways to tackle
it especially this problem where the
answer was a little bit simpler